well if you've got a television set in
your house you know perfectly well that
the media have been celebrating creepy
porn lawyer as a resistance hero for
months and months now but turns out
they're not just celebrating him but
actively protecting him by withholding
damaging information about him from you
the public to examples of this last June
creepy porn lawyer told Time magazine
that the Democrats absolutely needed to
nominate a white man in 2020 now I was
saying something like that would have
instantly wrecked his political career
as a Democrat there's nothing that
offends Democrats more than that phrase
but have no fear time did not tell you
that Democrats didn't know for months
because they sat on the story the
meantime creepy porn lawyer became a
national figure
NBC News by the way did exactly the same
thing too even more political effect
when creepy porn lawyer and his client
Julie sweat neck accused Brett Kavanaugh
of participating in a long series of
public gang rapes remember that creepy
porn layer presented a sworn statement
from a second woman that seemed to back
up some of sweating exclaims you
probably vaguely recall this well two
days after he released that sworn
statement the woman recanted the story
to NBC News reporters she said that Cpl
had quote twisted her words in other
words NBC News had credible information
that dramatically undermined accusations
against Brett Kavanaugh it would have
been nice to know that before the vote
but they didn't tell anybody huh are you
surprised well only if you imagine NBC
News was still a news organization and
not a particularly clumsy arm of the
Democratic Party which needless to say
they are because it was of course NBC
that leaked the Access Hollywood tape
The Washington Post just before the
presidential election in order to
influence the outcome of that election
and later protected Democratic donor and
accused rapist Harvey Weinstein they did
all that and yet it wasn't enough for
creepy porn lawyer even with NBC's
assistant it has been a tough couple of
weeks for him his client stormy Daniels
was ordered to pay Donald Trump's legal
fees his theatrics during the
have non-confirmation help put Brett
Kavanaugh on the Supreme Court now the
law firm that he runs is facing eviction
for failing to pay its rent he's still
one of the best-known Democratic
candidates for president though
how was he likely to do Chris Hahn is a
progressive radio host and a former aide
to Senator Chuck Schumer he joins us
tonight from Long Island for a creepy
porn lawyer update Chris it's great to
see you tonight
thank you so here's my theory so creepy
point lawyer makes baseless charges
against Brett Kavanaugh accusing him of
participating in a rape he says all of
these lunatic things he doesn't pay his
taxes he's obviously a discredited
figure and not one Democrat criticizes
him until he endorses the idea of and
I'm quoting a white man running for
president at which point all Democrats
like oh no it's over it's over
why did anyone note that before all of
it I have criticized him on this network
several times and said he will never be
the Democratic nominee for president I
do love his haircut I think it's
fantastic and a very efficient but I
have criticized him politically I think
he is the reason why Susan Collins voted
for Brett Kavanaugh because I thought
the sweat neck allegations were very
outrageous and hard to prove that said
he had an affidavit from a client he was
not the one defaming the President or
defaming Cavanaugh it was the client so
it is it you know look there are lots of
problems with people never he's a
sensationalist
I I agree with you up until there but I
just can't let you get away with the
lawyers dodge that it's the client so it
was creepy porn lawyer who brought these
allegations forward who took the
deposition who was the vehicle by which
the rest of us know that these
allegations were made and by the way
these allegations were taken with dead
serious touched by every news
organization in America practically not
this show but everybody else and
Democrats never said wait a second ten
gang rapes in a row that's ridiculous
they stood and they nodded a lot of oh
it's very serious a lot of people took
it you know took it less than serious
and a lot of people dismissed it and
thought that this was adding something
to what was some very credible
allegations against Cavanaugh and
we call him creepy poor lawyer because
he represented a porn star he represent
a trade he represented myself he
represented a porn star who we know was
paid money not to discuss her affair
with the President of the United States
so there is there you know that's what
we know has a question she took money
for a voluntary sexual relationship in
exchange for not talking about it we
used to call that expression mafia is
specialized in it but now we're totally
cool with it and we're blaming the guy
who had to pay the extortion money how
does that work exactly can we for that
now we don't we actually don't know
exactly how that money was proposed in
fact it could have been proposed by the
person who wanted to cover it up
not necessarily the porn star who
warning self-similar never gotten to the
bottom of that and the president he the
president's lawyers did settle the
matter so I think they were happy with
the arrangement oh so they didn't want
to talk about therefore they must be
guilty but just for the record I want to
get this on tape you're totally cool if
people have a consensual sexual
relationship and one of the most money
not to talk about it that's okay with
you I'm not that person breaks the Amero
anyway it's the it's the fault of the
guy paid off not to talk about it like
what world is that I am NOT I am not in
favor of extortion I was just pointing
out there calling them a porn lawyer
we know why we call the war lawyer we
got to remember why he's a poor lawyer
and who he represented not just it
wasn't like he was more money from the
porn stations that he's a creepy porn
lawyer anyway just wanted to clear that
up Chris thanks so much for clarifying
all that